good morning heck it's tuesday so three
and a half years ago i was diagnosed
with a disease called labyrinthitis
wherein part of my inner ear became
inflamed due to a viral infection all at
once i went from feeling like i had a
bit of a head cold to being completely
incapacitated by vertigo i fell over
began vomiting and was rushed to the
hospital and in the years since i've had
a lot of treatment for labyrinthitis and
i've started to wonder is this disease
mental or physical let me begin by
noting just how profoundly we stigmatize
mental illness when i was in the
hospital there was initially some
thought that my vertigo might be
psychosomatic that the dizziness could
be caused by my chronic anxiety and i
have to confess once they found an
ostensibly physiological cause for the
vertigo i was a little relieved because
suddenly everyone was acting as if and i
started feeling as if my illness was
really real but of course mental illness
is also really real and often has a
physiological cause like the brains of
many people who have ocd as i do look
different in fmri scans than the brains
of other people we just don't really
understand those differences very well
yet and illnesses that are poorly
understood or lack effective treatments
tend to be heavily stigmatized see also
endometriosis and irritable bowel
syndrome and many pain disorders and
leprosy rarely do i need a footnote in a
video but i do need one here the
category of mental illness is just that
a category it has uses and it has
limitations and remembering that
categories are often useful but almost
always limited seems to me one of the
big challenges of life right now like
the extremely silly discourse around
whether a hot dog is a sandwich is of
course very silly but underneath it lies
something important which is that we
want categories to be strict and
inviolable when in fact they are messy
and constructed but right so i got
labyrinthitis which is not a
psychological illness or at least i'm
told it's not i went home from the
hospital with two medications one a
central nervous depressant called
mechazine and the other an anti-anxiety
medication called diazepam that also
lessens vertigo both these medications
were psychotropic in the sense that they
affected the way i experience
consciousness and both of them are
sometimes prescribed as psychiatric
medications but in my case they weren't
psychiatric medications because in my
case my illness was not considered
psychiatric both these medications
reduced my symptoms while i recovered
but i eventually found that even after i
was mostly better and the virus was gone
i still had some sort of long-term
problems with my vestibular system so my
doctor sent me for therapy at a balance
institute so i went to this place to
retrain my brain's balance system and
while i was there the therapist said to
me we're just trying to rewire your
brain and in that moment i realized this
is just like the other therapy i go to
like in regular therapy i'm trying to
get my brain to respond differently to
unreliable anxious thoughts and in this
therapy i'm trying to get my brain to
respond differently to unreliable inner
ear information now the exercises and
medicines used to treat ocd are very
different from those to treat
labyrinthitis but the underlying idea is
similar medication and therapy and so is
it a mental or physical illness
yeah
yeah yes it is i find myself going back
again and again to elaine scary's
observation in the body in pain to have
great pain is to have certainty and to
hear that another person has pain is to
have doubt i think that doubt compounds
the suffering of people in pain and i
think it is further compounded when we
imagine that someone's illness or pain
is less real because it involves the
mind or because an observer can't see it
the truth is the mind-body dichotomy is
as insufficient as the category of
sandwiches our minds are made out of
body and our bodies think in fact on
earth at least bodies are the only
things that think whether we call it
mental or physical other people's pain
is as real as our own
hank i'll see you on friday